大家好,我是来自浙江大学的冯羽扬
今天我要分享的内容是
银与数据要塑现场目刻的综合案例与实践
跨企业数据查询
我的分享会按照如下三个部分进行
首先是本次实践的案例背景
然后是相关数据级的准备
最后是实验流程
在实验流程的部分
我将在银与的Secret Note实讯平台上
完成对整个实验的实际流程
好,首先我们先来看一下案例背景
假设有两家企业A和B
A是一家新型高科技企业
正在研发一种久突破性的生物可降解材料
这个产品尚未公开或者申请专利
为了避免重复的投入
A就想向企业B查询
这种材料是否已经被企业B所持有的历史书记录记录
但是出于保密的需求
A又不希望B
直到具体查询的哪一种材料
如果说B得知了A要查询的信息
那可能会导致A的研究方向或者深夜战略
就泄露给B了
或者B会对A的相关专利进行恶意抢注
甚至说B可能会将A的查询信息
倒卖给第三方等等风险
针对以上的场景
就可以使用你思计算中的逆宗查询
也就是PIR技术
在不泄露A所查询的信息的前提下
完成查询
好
在这里我再简单的介绍一下
PIR技术
PIR全称是Private Information Retrieval
它是用一种用于保护用户查询隐私的技术
通过使用PIR用户能够从一个数据库中查询某一项数据
同时又不让数据库的持有方
知道用户查询的是哪一项
PIR有如下的分类方法
第一种是按服务器的数量分类
可以分为单服务器PIR和多服务器PIR
第二种是按照查询类型分类
可以分为index PIR和keyword PIR
什么是index PIR呢
就是说我们可以把数据库的存储的数据
看作是一个数组
用户查询
它查询的是这个数组的下标爱
获得的是这个数组的下标爱对应的内容
VI
同时数据库的持有方
它没有办法获得关于爱的信息
keyword PIR可以看作是数据库中存储的若干个建值队
每一队就是keyword和VI
用户查询的是这个建值队中的键
也就是keyword
获得的是这个建值队中的植
也就是VI
同时数据库的持有方
也无法获得关于keyword的人和信息
那本次实践
我们使用的就是单符系的keyword PIR
好
接下来我们来看一下数据级的准备
企业b的数据级包括两部分
一个是db.csv
用于模拟数据库
包含了k和value两列
然后一共有若干行取值
每行取值就代表一个建值队
然后另一个文件是serversecretkey.bin
这个是企业b在pr中使用的密钥
然后企业的数据级包含一个文件
prquery.csv
这个文件用于记录代查询的件
然后它只包含了一列k
而且也只有一行取值
在这里就是fr
在这个例子中a进行查询之后
它就能够获得fr在b的数据库中对应的value值
也就是这里的rm
好的
下面是实验的整体流程
分为四大步
然后第一步是获取可用的端口
并配置瑞极群
第二步是再次获取可用端口
并且配置spu
那这两步属于是实验的前期准备工作
与pr的关系并不是很大
然后第三步是pr的setup阶段
这一步由server单独执行
server就是企业b
这一步server会用密钥
将自己的名文数据库加密
得到加密后的密文数据库
然后最后一步是pr的online阶段
这一步由双方共同执行
然后在这一步client
就是企业a会发起查询
并且在不泄漏查询信息的前提下得到结果
那下面我将在英语的server的实讯平台上
完成整个实验的实际操作流程
好的
现在我们已经打开了英语secretnose实讯平台
为了节省时间
我已经启动了节点client和server
可以在右上角查看节点的相关的详细信息
同时我已经将实验所需的文件
分别上传到了对应节点中
可以在左侧查看
这个是server对应的数据库文件
好
我们可以在这里以表格的形式预览
然后这个是client对应的查询文件
好
现在我们正式开始进行实验
实验背景刚刚已经介绍过
这里就不再坠述
然后这里client节点就对应了
实验背景中发起查询的企业a
server节点对应企业b
首先我们来尝试执行第一个代码块
导入用英语进行影子计算所需要的两个包
分别是secret flow和spu
其他的包我们就在需要的时候再导入
好
可以看到这个代码块的右上角
标记了client和server可以进行修改
这个是什么意思呢
就代表这个代码块
它是由client和server共同分别执行的
点击右侧的运行按钮
client和server就会共同地去运行这个代码块
好可以看到这个代码块也是运行成功了
好
下面我们来进行实验的第一步
获取可用端口
并进行锐集群的page
首先我们需要获取可用的端口
双方节点需要从侧定的端口执行不同的任务
因此我们需要执行下属按use的tcp part
函数来查找微卑站的端口
好
每次运行这个函数的时候
查找的到端口可能都是不同的
好
下面这一端代码就是对
按use的tcp part的实现
我们直接运行这一端代码
好
可以看到client和server分别输出了一个端口号
下面我们会使用这两个端口号对节点进行初始化
好
下面我们进行节点锐集群的初始化
初始化通过调用函数sf.init来进行
sf.init谈数主要接收这两个参数
一个是address代表了锐集群的地址
另一个是cluster config
也就是相关的配置信息
然后在cluster config中
我们主要是需要输入两个参数
一个是parties
一个是self party
parties就表示所有参与方的端口信息
这里有两个参与方client和server
所以只有这两项
然后self party就表示自身是哪一个参与方
在执行代码之前
我们需要将parties的参数替换为实际的IP和端口
其中IP地址可以在右上角的节点信息中查看
我们点击这里
然后这里可以复制节点的IP信息
然后在这里进行替换
然后相应的端口号也使用我们刚刚输出的端口号
同样的对server也进行相应的替换
然后这个是client代码块
由于client和server
他们的self party参数其实是不同的
所以他们需要在两个代码块中执行
这里我们需要把这里的信息
复制到下一个代码块中
好
行 现在我们已经完成了替换
现在需要同时执行这两个代码块
为了同时执行这两个代码块
我们可以这样把光标放在此处
然后点击执行上方所有self
这样我们就可以执行前面的所有代码块
好
虽然前面的其他代码块也会再执行一次
不过对实验是没有影响的
我们也可以看到这两个代码块也是正常的执行完毕了
第二步是对spu进行page
由于pi而主要是基于spu进行实验
所以我们首先需要对spu进行page
在page spu的时候
参议方需要从新的端口启动参与计算
也就是说我们需要再执行一次I use的tcp part
来获取一对未使用的端口号
好的
下面我们需要执行sf.spu函数创建spu实例
spu函数接收的page参数为cluster.def
我们在spu.conf里面对相关的参数进行page
spu.conf主要包含两个参数
一个是nose
还有一个是random.config
nose里面包含了节点的名称以及地址等信息
而random.config用于设置安全计算的参数
其中Pertical参数表示使用的多方安全计算协议
这里使用的协议是3m2k
File的参数表示计算使用的有限预
这里是128bit
SigmoidMode表示SigmoidMode含述的进次方式
这里采用的是SigmoidRail这一进次方式
然后我们仍然是要在nose参数下面对节点的IP和端口进行替换
这里我已经替换了节点的IP
下面我们替换一下节点的端口
然后执行代码
可以看到代码顺利地执行
第三步是pr的setup阶段
这一步服务提供方server需要对明文数据库进行加密
通过调用spu的prsetup含述
server对明文数据库db.sasv进行加密
最后将结果输出到文件sdb中
这一步需要获取当前的文件位置
在secretnose在线平台中
实验人员可以通过执行os.getcwd含述
获取当前的工作空间路径
这里把它存到curantdir这个辨量中
prsetup有如下参数
其中server表示被查询方的节点的名称
这里被查询方的节点的名称就是server
inputpass表示明文数据库的路径
这里直接填入对应的路径即可
kcolumns表示数据库中
键值对中的键对应的sas文件的哪一列
这里对应的是k这一列
labelcolumns表示的是数据库中
键值对中的值对应的是sas文件中的哪几列
这里对应的是value这一列
oprfkpass是蜜药的路径
这里添入对应的路径即可
namproquery表示的是client查询时查询的条目数量
由于client每次只查询一条
这里添入一即可
labelmaxlem表示键值对中值的最大程度
这里我们可以直接把它设为史留一点荣誉
setuppass表示的是输出的加密数据库的路径
我们这里让加密的数据库输出到工作目录下的sdb文件中
然后最后是bucket size
这个表示对数据库进行分统的统大小
由于我们使用的数据库规模较小
所以这里设为十即可
好然后我们运行这转代码
好可以看到代码成功的执行
并且刷新这里的目录
可以看到server的工作区域多了一个sdb文件
它就是加密之后的数据库
好的最后一步是双方执行pr的online阶段
在online阶段需要在不泄漏查询方client查询信息的情况下得到查询结果
在第三步中
server已经将加密后的数据库保存至工作目录下的文件sdb中
此外还需要将server的密要
也就是serversecretk.bin移动到server所在容器的tmp目录下
我们执行如下的代码将密要复制到tmp目录下
好的然后我们编写pr任务本实验以k为主键
查询prquery.csv并将查询结果输出到prsauce.csv文件中
查询方式是调用spu.pi而query
这个函数包含6个函数
首先是server和client表示被查询方和查询方的节点名称
这里被查询方的节点名称就是server
查询方的节点名称就是client
然后是server set of paths
这个参数代表被查询方的加密数据库的路径
也就是stb的路径
第四个参数是client k columns
这个参数代表查询方所查询的文件
也就是prquery.csv中
查询值所在的那一列的列名也就是k
第五个参数是client input paths
这个参数代表查询方所查询的文件prquery.csv的存储路径
第六个参数是client output paths
这个参数代表查询方查询文件的输出路径
查询结果的输出路径
然后我们执行这个代码块
然后刷新一下左侧的文件列表
可以看到这里多出来了一个pr result.csv
这个就是所查询的结果
然后打开这个文件
可以看到fr对应的结果是rm
它的结果也是正确的
好的那么这就是我们的跨企业数据查询的时间案例